it's gonna take a lot more than that to
give me the spook but this always hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to the eagerly awaited
bendy in the ink machine that Chapter
four therefore now if you are wondering
Oh where's Chapter three I've already
played it on a live stream so with that
being said let's get into the colossal
wonders of chapter four of bendy in the
ink machine also a big reminder
everybody in Australia we are coming to
you November links in the description
will tell you when our tour is going to
arrive in a city near you and Amsterdam
coming back in July links in the
description as well now let's see ok
where we last left off death befell all
of our enemies I mean not to that in
level of extent I mean for the most part
we seem to still be in a world of hurt
and our elevator seems to have crash
hold as hard as it could and we're at
the lowest level that we could possibly
ever get to and I'm still glugging down
swoop like nobody's business
shape songs with Boris the Beatles
so just to recap everybody gather round
and listen close so as a recap bendy and
the Machine is about a horribly
monstrous entertainment industry kinda
like the one we have right now but where
Inc comes alive and everything is
colored in sepia everything is in an
Instagram filter in this world horrible
I know but hopefully this one will be a
little less errand d than the last one
cuz that was always my problem with
these games I love the story love the
atmosphere there's a reason it got so
popular it's because of this really
unique take on it and kind of turning
Disney into this perverse Empire of
horribleness
for me something missing here definitely
something missing here my valve vision
can tell me that there's some really
been missing it but we've plumbed the
depths of this as a former employee
ourselves we have to go back into this
destitute and decrepit destitute and
decrepit location with which we will
discover the true secret of the ink
machine that fuels this horrible short
wait a minute bubble bubble toil and
trouble what's going on here all right
fine
okay okay time is money
Hey oh okay we're gonna die
somebody here gonna die hey I found the
missile thing
I'm guessing this was the accountants
office and I'm guessing that the
accountant has turned into a bubble of
oily goo which is usually what happens
when accountants retire now the other
thing that this game is known for is
incredible number of Secrets so if you
see something that I do not see be sure
to point it out in the comments below
[Music]
hello sorry this is a strip club I
didn't want to go here I wanted to find
out where I'm going
ah he will set us free yeah you look it
yeah you look real free oh you look so
free I've never seen such freedom in my
life
I'm just getting a good look at these
guys and they do not look too happy but
they do seem to be I don't know
worshipping a bendy idol no no I just
got to find Boris or one of his many
clones because apparently there are many
of those now I wouldn't be fool enough
to think that every single one of those
Boris's is gonna be good to me I know
that some of them are probably gonna be
a rotten stone cold bastard
and saying things behind closed doors I
can always tell now he wants to meet
again tomorrow
mmm seems like little ol Suzy is reading
too much into a role as Alison kind of
blurring the lines in between what's
real and what's not real so what's in
here that I need these saves seem to be
open this private okay suppose Oh
all right and up
we're not on a boat so it's not like the
whole place is rocking back and forth
we're underground I hear you ah that's
my design that's the creepiest thing
ever that's really good ambience because
that I love what I'm hearing is someone
creeping around here
while I'm in here which is a really
creepy thing to think when you think
about it and if that's true then by
goodness gravy they're doing a good job
here okay okay so there's some kind of a
puzzle here I've got to activate this
door and I don't know these these seem
to be not there doesn't seem to be any
usable interactions here that doesn't
seem to be anything here but then again
these puzzles in this game are awfully
obscure sometimes so just trying to take
a look around the full area before we
jump to conclusions okay there were five
lights which means that there's five oh
here we go so that's how it works now
the real smarty yeah okay all right I
got it boo that is how it works so I had
to hit that one first before I hit any
of the other ones that are very clearly
and obviously here because I tried to
push that but just didn't take now did
it all right I got you
I understand you oh my word my goodness
gravy why would you do that I'm a
sensitive little baby I don't know if
there'd be any out here it doesn't look
like it Oh
I don't know why that took so long to
register but oh hey they're gone
oh it's a Big Bend oh it's a Big Bend
efface I didn't even notice that good
this is going well for me this is fine
the last two and now I think it's a more
tangible threat okay
easy as pie easy as big old enter the
darkness enter oh okay by the objective
of enter the darkness then that's
darkness that's real dark just dark down
there
it's dark down there so I'm thinking you
don't mean that but maybe you do maybe I
need to leave off I can't I can't won't
let me okay that's probably for the best
this is oh this is not good is this
where the the remnants of the remnants
of the ink machine like it wanders off
because in the very first chapter
there was an ink machine but I don't
think that was the ink machine maybe the
ink ooh the machine is spread like a
virus throughout the entirety of this
complex and there's no stopping its
eternal spread across gonna go for you
buddy boo huh they're gonna go good for
you I don't think it's gonna go good for
you I think it's gonna go the way you
think it's gonna go I think that these
guys are gonna try to stop you no matter
what no matter what you do you're never
gonna be able to do any Lukey
you're not dad
okay I don't want to know why this looks
like Darth Vader's meditation chamber I
don't want to know it all actually I
just do you know I'd rather not know
[Music]
I love that I thank you I think I've got
a glob of a goo
where do i chef this goo this magical
repair goo is gonna fix everything
he's shove it in here I've got a goo
come on tell me where to shove my goo
[Music]
that's why everything looks like it's
drawn on paper they sink everything here
is ink everything is the goo
everything's made from the goo
everything is the goo they use the goo
for everything and that's why everything
is going wrong the imagination comes to
reality through the magic of this
goddamn dude who's gonna make another
cup as it goes go spit out random ok so
there's gotta be something with this goo
can make something more than a cup right
this guy is just so chill about this I
question this a little bit but you know
I'm not gonna question it too much cuz I
don't want to but there's got to be some
kind of machination or machine here
that's gonna give me a cranky yank a
gear as it's called so it's not that one
so it's gotta be something else
but that's fascinating that's why those
things are alive
that's why everything here is alive now
see this is what I like about bendy and
the machine is because it really does
tap into some pretty weird stuff but
when you bring out things like this it
starts to make sense it starts to make
sense in that weird way that things make
sense when you're not - right in the
hand when you're thinking about things
that shouldn't be thought about so much
you get into the mood and then when you
get in that mood you start to let
insanity creep in on you and you start
to be willing to use this stuff for
things that aren't supposed to exist and
that's how people can blend together
that's how everything can start to take
a life of its own they found this
magical magical egg machine and so long
as they kept it running everything would
be okay that's fast
I wonder if I'd just slap it here can it
work no I need to make a gear okay I'll
be right back I'm gonna figure this out
but I'll be right back
wait oh here we go top gear whatever
that is bone give me a bone I'm gonna
give it to chica come on come on bone
that's too realistic
and that is how they made so many
Boris's and that probably means that
there's more than one bendy unless it's
all bendy unless that's the whole thing
right and then that means that soup that
soup ain't soup if they printed the soup
and the guthe and that's just goo and
we're all eating go the ramifications of
this are never-ending let me find out
what the this is I want to find out
[Music]
but that's such an elegant concept sorry
I'm geeking out about how cool that is
that is environmental storytelling right
there
okay let's not get distracted by how
amazed I am at all this so we got to put
this in here wink and we got to turn it
over to Frankie ank you don't need a
anything but this got the cranky ank
but here smash it out and then suddenly
a whole world the possibility opens up
right before our eyes what happened to
that what happened the labor just kind
of disappeared should I not be concerned
about that all right okay we're gonna
pretend like that didn't just happen
we're gonna be able to come back at some
point
all right hippity-hop e on to the candy
shop to be back very slowly almost too
slowly
it's very disturbingly slow it's almost
a bad mystery for something could go
wrong
all right a funny feeling
[Music]
I said ICO that's how you're gonna be
game huh oh you're gonna fake me out
well I'm I'm a veteran of hundreds and
hundreds of horror games it's gonna take
a lot more than that to give me the
spook
but this hallway by do it okay
I regret to calm down I know it's a no
no means no and I'm glad you respect
that okay it seems like probably from
all the soup I ate maybe it was like a
choice maybe that first soup can if I
hadn't eaten that help would be a little
bit better please don't call me that
great
[Music]
okay all right he's saying that like
he's easy cut in half or is he like
mentally degrading or is he just like I
don't know he's not really into one
piece the anime and he's just like he
wanted to get into it but he couldn't
really like start you know where he got
started and it was just like it petered
out after a few dozen seasons you know
No
okay get some more information and
please don't send me on any more errands
that was really uncool of you last time
all right
soup well too late now doesn't serve
that in my gob now that I know what
that's all about I'm gonna eat a whole
this soup I don't know why they're
giving me soup anyway they're giving me
soup here
but I don't need soup so there's got to
be something to that maybe there's
multiple endings on this one because
there are choices in this game to be
made there are choices to be made and
then maybe after all of this is released
maybe there's actually gonna be some
choices that carry over from each one to
the next one I know not for I make
stupid choices oh hi
where do we go home
okay I'm guessing never I'm guessing
never is the answer to that one can I
hide I can I don't know why would all
right pooping are done pooping did that
save I think that wasn't that the same
mechanic last time I don't know oh I'll
take that thank you
is that a watermelon with the camera in
it okay whatever maybe I don't know okay
you know what I'm just gonna back away
slowly I didn't mean going there okay I
don't know why but for some reason
looking in this general direction makes
my computer slow down so I'm guessing
it's because all of you guys are here
and you're very yep yeah I feel like
this is it well I don't like this and
we've got it in cinematic horror vision
alright alright we are wise whew got
some soup okay I don't know what that is
but I'll take it
oh yeah I'd wait watch good good oh hi
you know I I wanted to check if there
was soup there but I guess right well
only one way to go I've made some errors
I shouldn't have rushed through but what
can you do carrying on as if nothing is
wrong
oh I don't like that [ __ ] shush I wasn't
being too loud when I was screaming in
terror was I I think this game is
remembering what it was
this game is scary oh really really
scary Oh dead end okay but that's good I
like it
I need that it should be that this is a
horrible environment and there's only
one chapter after this I think but this
is cool stuff this is really cool stuff
okay oh oh no no no no I remember a very
similar scene from dead space or no
please don't do that
please don't okay thank you I'm guessing
what I'm guessing that's all about is
the people who worked here after
ingesting the soup googley started to
change like their body was taken over in
this goo form because like they say if
your body is replaced one atom at a time
very slowly but if it's replaced one
atom at a time with something that's
functionally similar but altogether
different when would you notice when
would you become something else at what
point would you stop being yourself and
become elegantly as I could have put
that but when do you become come up and
see me okay I'm definitely eager about
that let me just poop this go out okay
we're good almost here
[Music]
great what are you building up towards
got a soup I'm real hungry
okay all right
egotistical much I mean I would know
given that I'm egotistical to a very
humble degree but what does this lever
do great
I open storage number nine so Bertram
there is the architect of all of this
but not necessarily the originator of
the cartoons
good old birdie there is on a bit of an
ego trip but maybe it's justified is
that a footlocker I can open can I
crouch how do I crouch tonight please I
know you got soup in you ignoring that
let's just keep going back storage
number nine is open you Shh I don't like
the monoliths the bendy there just seems
a little too much like warriors shoe and
why did I get my flashlight that GU
cheap like God buddy
nd hell tremendous fun for everybody
right okay
tremendous fun you say how's your
madness are we talking about and how
much will I okay funny joke it was funny
last time not funny now Oh strength
tester I'm on I'm gonna be a man baby
now seems like the way to go but it's
gonna need some power oh yeah here we go
no come on
oh man baby lies no go get it
am i hitting it no man come on
I'm better than a man baby hey hey look
you don't judge how I do if you're gonna
watch me then you're gonna watch every
moment of my life including the bathroom
and this ping pong Beller - shut up ass
hole okay we got to get power back on
somehow okay never mind none of those
work I guess I gotta do this the
old-fashioned way with I don't know key
or something there was a tip that said
search the warehouse but there's a savvy
doodad if that is indeed svb dad I think
this is to see me do that if it's not a
savvy dudette than I'm taking a
gratuitous amount of [ __ ] that means
there's a lot of gold oh the traps ah I
thought it was like some kind of a the
green guy from The Muppet from Sesame
Street I forget his name Rana Groucho
whatever his name was but their trash
cans which is somehow workers so
somewhere in here there's got to be
something that can help me get the power
back on oh wait a minute how did I miss
this
oh hell yeah
oh hell yeah wow what a genius idea of
so smart all right no one judge that all
right nailed it okay there we go it's at
the bottom of the scoop oh okay that's
baloney well this is a bunch of belong
curse that was win Hey
okay I'll take it whatever all right I
got me begun I'm gonna show you what's
business Oh No
Oh BAM got it Oh BAM
we gotta hit the X that's how it goes oh
no not the axe
I knew that but I was just saying you
know I like hitting the farty noise one
good thing I'm so good at shooters okay
or don't click oh wait that was not a
win or I'm gonna assume that's not a
whoa
I don't know what the blast-off is but
I'm curious damn it what the Frick
what the Frick know I can do I can do it
hang on everybody shut up this worth it
hey did I win what screw you guys okay
whatever I don't even care anymore oh I
care I care deeply I care yeah that's
one all right that's that is that is one
you are right you dad that was one one
got him really nailed it I guys Bose
soap great - got the soap one of those
must have opened something else but I
don't know what because I just gotta
keep checking the doors maybe they only
opened one at a time maybe this one got
open - I don't know nope okay so that's
kind of cool now let's just see what
this does
all right number one did that did that
do something sir do you know what that
did it's glowing here now but maybe it
was always going
let me poop think about this really poop
poop the good old poop think oh hey oh
this is open now I didn't know this
wasn't open just a second ago
okay more soot I had some company up
ahead about some kind of weapon I don't
stand a chance
there's gotta be a way around them oh I
was operating under the assumption now I
was gonna munch munch on that that oh
yeah get the goods oh yeah that's good
stuff okay so I got to distract him
maybe if I throw it into the fire
they're all just diving in headfirst
okay or maybe I can do something else to
it I can't crouch so I can't exactly be
stool theabout it but what I can do is
the word I'm into corners war as out of
face okay that's a face alright that's a
face
the big old face well the can do is I
can lure them into areas where I'm gonna
need to go that it's a big arm wait
thanks wait a minute
that's big arm like that's that's a big
arm that's arm is proportionally too big
for even those big faces why do you need
that that big why is that in this as Uzi
I remember fighting those guys in the
last one it was a bit annoying but
because they've changed up combat for
really ok what if I toss it down I don't
know how long you're gonna stay there I
doubt they're gonna stay there very long
so maybe that'll be good
I used three cans on it that wasn't a
good idea but you know I'm never okay
they're back already
Jesus okay maybe I can just since
they're not facing me I guess yeah I
could just you know kind of like do one
of these moves [ __ ] Oh am I just
gonna die is this just my death now I
guess I don't know I don't know what's
happening I thought they were gonna hit
me in one shot Bindu apparently not okay
alright can I have the soup please oh
boy the Creator lied to us I'm about to
be lied to incredibly well [ __ ] hi okay
alright I figured as much
oh okay is this the gigantic inky
butthole of the afterlife I don't know
what I'm doing it but do i oh I can move
oh I got a walk towards the light I
thought I was just channeling through
there it's some kind of weird birth
thing Oh gross oooh
oh just really yeah I don't know where
to toss him cuz it came back so quickly
I can't exactly be over here and run all
the way back so what's got to be has got
to be some confirmation of or
conformation of
you know tossing it over did making how
is this just a baby throw what's behind
I can't look behind but was it big house
it a little itty bitty baby throw okay
we made okay easy as that I don't know
why the first one was a baby throw but
whatever hey what's going on crybaby who
do cry made goo tears oh no oh you lost
your why did God wait goo we need to be
whatever you want form yourself into
something different if you're so sad
alright I'm sorry I feel bad I don't
know I'm berating you I'm just upset
okay let's hear what this had to say
[Applause]
you talking you talking about that
animatronic looking thing you talk you
talked about mr. annemun tromo here
that's opening up a new door why does it
need to be mechanical you could make him
lifelike anyway you didn't need to make
him a robot it was the point of making
him a robot apparently the electricity
was already on so let's try this no no
no oh no no come on guys no all right
back into the butthole I guess
apparently from my last death sprint
there was already out there I kind of
want to see what's in that little nook
and cranny over in the other corner
before I leave because the power may be
on but I'm I'm not necessarily done so
here all we got to do is not do a baby
throw maybe I needed to come over here
but I don't know what that was
okay that did a thing I don't know what
that thing was what it did a thing also
there's IOU written right there as
confusing to say the least
okay I don't know how to get them then
if I do for they're too
oh oh no we're fine we're fine
whoa we're fine okay we're fine okay
we're good we're going out there they're
not gonna get me and we're all good okay
so I got what I needed and then I
activated power to something that
sounded like a train of some sort but I
don't know why there would be a train
over here hey either way we got power
and I don't think that would have been
two different powers it's only one maybe
I need both of them for this but it
opened something one of these other
doors must be open now right that's how
this works it's an exchange I think that
doors open over there I don't know why I
didn't just go over there and check but
then again I'm a dumbass so what do I
really know anyway yes it's open okay so
what do we got down this hall Oh close
me in here we've got what it what I'm
worried what in my way minute what am I
looking at oh it's oh it's one of the
dudes I never really took the time to
look at you oh you're not fun oh you're
a horrible Oh
it's like a piranha attached to the
butthole of a face you all right more
soup for me I guess not that I need it
then why do I keep drinking it
Oh mr. drew for all your talk of dreams
you are the true architect behind so
many nightmares
I built this park it was to be a
masterpiece my masterpiece
[Music]
[Applause]
oh oh hi okay
that's awful that's horrible that's
horrible
oh okay oh how why would you do that to
yourself sir Bernie what would you do
that oh my word
Wow Wow
okay uh that's horrifying I don't want
look at that I don't know what I'm doing
I don't know what I'm doing okay all
right can you not do whatever you're
about okay that guy's okay all right can
i skadoodle nope okay don't understand
what I'm supposed to be do okay you're
back out of it oh god I don't like the
way he looks at me God the first thing
I've ever seen and I still don't even
understand why wow that was close
okay well I guess I'm fine then if I
just skirt around the outside
there's gotta be so hello that's a thing
that's glowing and weird so I'm gonna go
towards that I guess and I've never
thought I would say that to go towards
this big glowing thing okay it's nothing
it was just soup I don't know why I did
this
I don't know what I'm trying to do here
there's got to be like some way to turn
him off right now he's very turned on I
know I'm very handsome so he just got
aroused by my alluring figure I just got
to cover myself up so he gets less you
know aroused hmm what happens if I get
too close
hey Barney whoo hey Bernie okay of all
the rides to turn yourself into in a
horrible Frankenstein Ian incident I
don't know if I would have gone with the
octopus tilt the world thing but okay
those are glowing wait these are glowing
hang on let me let me just see if I can
do something about these nope okay I
need some kind of a tool oh oh oh
what's here really it was there the
whole time oh well goodness gravy I
didn't know that was there I didn't see
the axe so you can't
for not picking it up coz who would have
known all right come on this is gonna be
a trial of attrition I'm gonna slowly
smash you up oh yeah that's a good stuff
give me give me a look at that
oh yeah that's gone you know deserve
that or that no no not today not today
not today not ever actually if you
really think about it
whap whap it whoa okay well that's gone
uh-oh I was too close
Bernie Bernie Oh Bernie Bernie Bernie
let's let's listen to reason now you
seem like a reasonable person only a
reasonable person would put him into
such a predicament as this all right
Bernie listen I'm gonna do this and then
I'm gonna run because I didn't know that
I needed to run so quickly yeesh all
right this one's going down Oh
run run whoa whoa whoa whoa that is
inches from my face sir thank you
all right so I just got to get these two
but I don't think I can do them in one
fell swoop if I do get in the angle I
probably could but something tells me
I'm not gonna get in the proper angle oh
no I'm definitely not gonna get in the
proper angle dangle now well [ __ ] I've
really goofed myself okay another one
biting the dust and presently I can't
get Bernie listen calm down man it's not
not worth it man Bernie look don't look
at me with those oh okay you're gonna
really you're gonna move it all the way
over there you know it's your own fault
I could have been reasonable about this
but you whoa hey kaboom Hey oh stop
there's a sense - oh no you're saying I
you're dying okay well that was
definitely an interesting boss I've
never fought an amusement park ride
before I've been on an amusement park
ride and terrible things have happened
ah ah the park but necessarily do it
straight up like that so thank you that
was a
oh yes it's my normal blase about all of
this I was fighting an amusement ride
I've worked here for 40 years I know
exactly what I'm doing
and I'm killing you so don't try to stop
me with your boos Huawei's only one more
door to go and I'm pretty sure as soon
as I flip this switch it's gonna open it
up I don't know what the angel has to do
with all this by the way like the angel
is just a person like that got a little
too egotistical about everything and
apparently they're the only one left but
Bernie Bernard or burnt room whatever it
is choo choo choo he was actually an
architect about all this
ride the buddy Boris railways why can't
I my god jump oh my god jump okay I just
know I gotta actually move my cut sees a
little bit okay let me pop a little bit
lots of goo going through me okay we're
done all right
oh no I killed you I killed you I killed
this [ __ ] I killed you I killed you
dead I killed you very varied okay I
want you to you could not be whomped no
more I don't want to know what I'm
looking at are these hearts Oh Boris is
that you man if that means like I just
thought that's a Boris plushie what if
all these plushies were made from the
very same goo and therefore they're all
technically alive everything in here is
technically alive isn't it maybe it's
not a good idea to play this tape but
I'm gonna do
well-well hell oh no you don't no no no
I was trying to run away from you
because I was trying to get the end of
the message but then I couldn't okay I
don't believe ya all right I don't know
what I'm supposed to do here I guess I
just run away until I die or do I flip
this switch and then that's the end of
it
okay whatever lift control sure oh this
is so by me okay it is okay all right
well farewell I think I don't know why
that was a necessity but okay maybe it
heard it anyway glug
so coming what do I do you'll never find
me I'm a secret look see uh-huh
secret you can't find me you can't you
can't no you can't find me see I'm not
oh okay all right well I didn't work out
too well time to go down the the big
butt hole of time and space it's like
Doctor Who Doctor Who took place on the
Magic School Bus and you went inside
Arnold's a noose what I just you can't
do that I just maybe he's supposed to be
chasing me this whole time or maybe it's
just a bog all right whatever let's find
whatever we're supposed to be doing here
oh the power oh that's easy enough
Oh
[Music]
okay
all's well that ends well don't need to
be worried about every little thing okay
how did I know how did I know can I hide
in the pooper
I seem to recall being able to hide in
the pooper before oh oh hi no I sighs
whooping you know that you know the
rules of poop oh I don't know it's sad
I'm rooting for him okay hey buddy are
you how you doing okay all right see ya
so far were fairly well farewell
farewell
okay oh that doesn't make sense that
doesn't make sense that just doesn't
make sense how do you drag him through
nothing well how are you still spreading
out goop can I take this is that
valuable to me well I guess he's dead
but then again I killed him in the last
chapter so really who is the more badass
alright but anyway that was the last one
so whatever I needed to do I've done it
cool great rescue Boris okay all right
I'm down I'm down I mean that's what I
set out to do in the beginning anyway
turn back well did you just trick me did
you give me a goof oh I don't like to be
goofed like this I'm not gonna turn back
time this close to rescuing Boris let's
do this you laughing or farting I can't
tell which okay cool that's great
all right that sounds good
well ok with that yeah I don't need I
don't need to actually go through this I
can repress it what are you saying where
did it all go so wrong but you probably
are
okay what's that let's say what's the
surprise what's it what is it it's a
drop
I like drop towers it's like oh it's
like the haunted house from Disneyland a
haunted mansion ooh how did people get
in here to ride this ride when it's
Underground
but it's cool I'm not gonna question it
too much I like it I like the style Oh
weird
where is he gonna pop out so maybe I'm
close to getting all the super and
that's got to be like an achievement or
something or there's got to be some to
that like right yeah it was gotta be I
got that suit cuz otherwise
already doing it whoa whoa hey what has
she done to you
Orr's Oh Oh Horace bars no bars no okay
okay
how about you don't okay all right okay
so I guess he's the basic charging style
monster Oh oh he don't look so good
maybe I need to whomp him
okay so he's just got a run into stuff
all right can he run through the he can
he can he can't womp okay he got he
bonked his noodle he don't like that no
he oh I see I see I see okay I gotcha
okay so what I need to do rod until oh
she's gonna charge you to go charge I
saw somewhere I saw somewhere there was
a crafty machine it's over there okay so
he just can't can't let him destroy the
crafting machine even though I don't
think he could go you gonna roar you
gonna roar big guy
oh yeah he's roaring okay so set Wow oh
he tracks okay oh all right I wish I
didn't drink that soup it wasn't so much
of an achievement to drink that soup as
it just kind of stupid I guess
I'm borrow okay here we go okay so he's
in there I don't think he can destroy
this thing here no oh that looks good oh
those bars
nope okay give me this I'm gonna whomp
you sorry bar it's got to put you down
you're bad doggie bad doggie bad oh hey
wait a minute
what back Oh smash okay little weird but
alright hey back up hey back up hey back
up bars bars let's talk about this let's
talk about this Oh Boris Boris what oh
okay all right
Hulk smash Wow I've been smashed Hulk
alley all right whatever back into the
fray
all right straight back Oh everything's
back to square one okay alright we're
gonna get back into it just give me a
second what if I give him a bone
don't dogs like bones can I give him a
bone dog like bones right dog you my
bone bone bone no he likes it oh he
doesn't like it you don't like it okay
all right I tried though you know I
tried I'm gonna whomp you and I'm gonna
scoop of goop when you're warm
oh yeah okay we're just shoot you shot
goo I saw google shootie shoot again how
the bloody hell oh alright I see that
goop where are you going big guy
was he was he trying to break the trend
he's just throwing tantrum now he's just
throwing a tantrum oh oh oh oh oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh no oh ye okay all
right then well that's it seems unfair
I've got I've got this okay you missed
maybe I can whomp you if I go oh no
don't do that okay that's a no-no that's
a big no-no okay that's a big no-no okay
he just gets tuckered real tougher to
eat my Wheaties
[Music]
hey whoa lady whoa okay hey okay hey are
you doing are you doing
it's me Marga boy I'm pretty cool
alright well ah alright cool
I'm very confused but the whole concept
of everything being inked and everything
coming from the goo makes a lot of sense
but that is bendy and the ink machine
chapter 4 thank you everybody so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed this it
won't be too much longer until bendy and
the ink machine chapter 5 maybe another
few months or so but this is fun this
one was better than the last one because
while we were running around we were
running around with more purpose each
one seemed sequential to the next
instead of seeming a back-and-forth
constantly it was like it was like
different rooms of a haunted house
instead of just a series of events
lining up in front of another and then
looping back over and over again this
one was good I liked it what scary -
especially in the beginning later on it
got less scary but in the beginning that
was quite scary so thank you again
everybody so much for watching and
remember everybody in Australia we're
coming on tour to you in November check
out the link in the description below to
see when we're going to be coming to a
city near you and for those of you in
Amsterdam who missed our show and we
came back bye we are coming again in
July so check out the link in the
description below as well for that thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know if you want to see more cool
games like this and if you have more
cool ideas let me know down in the
comments as well thanks again everybody
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]